cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com this is crazy Japan would
send up balloons carrying bombs that
would ride the jet stream for thousands
of miles and then eventually drop the
bombs on the United States in random
locations most of them just hit Fields
though yeah that's a problem with trying
to do that to the US especially it's
such a spread out country China was able
to do it again they found out a way to
get a balloon over us so
man that's crazy and I remember when I
was little I watched a documentary about
it and it was like it had the system
where if it started to go too low
pressure the pressure in the in the
balloon would you know be going uh down
and then it would cause a bag to drop
which would then make it go back up
where the pressure would expand and then
as it started to go back down it would
drop another go back up yeah and they
timed it through this mechanisms to drop
once it traveled a certain amount of you
know time to hit the United States yeah
I watched some video apparently like
some kids found a bomb and hit it with a
rock and it blew up and killed him or
something oh my gosh well I mean like
you're running through the woods and you
find an explosive device kids are stupid
that's sad part about what's happened in
Ukraine now too I imagine the mind
they're mining though it's just not only
depleted uranium rounds underground
they're just irradiating the soil but
like just the the land mines and stuff
left over drones that go Rogue that fly
off and they're like I don't know where
it went you know we didn't see it
explode it's just gone we don't know
where it went kid's gonna find that
drone you know like people are gonna
find they're gonna stumble across it oh
here we go look at this May 5th 1945 six
civilians were killed near Bly Oregon
when they discovered one of the balloon
bombs in Fremont National Forest
becoming the only fatalities from axis
action in the continental U.S during the
war that's not to say I think it only
hit people once yeah I guess they didn't
hit him right exactly this must have
been the story it's uh Reverend Archie
Mitchell and his pregnant wife drove up
gearheart mountain today with five of
their Sunday school students in a picnic
when Archie was parking the car Elsie
and the children discovered a balloon
and carriage loaded with an
anti-personnel bomb on the ground a
large explosion occurred the four boys
uh were killed instantly while Elsie and
Joan patsky died from their wounds
shortly after an army investigation
concluded the bomb had likely been
kicked or dropped and that it had Lane
undisturbed for about one month before
the incident so that's what it was I was
that must have been what I had been
watching so they kicked it I guess the
Assumption was the kids ran up to it
they're like hey look an explosive and
they kicked it and then it blew up so
and people got to understand too there
are undetonated bombs in in southeast
Asia oh boy be careful there's a lot of
there's a lot of places
um I had a friend who went to Cambodia
and uh
was working with uh like the these uh I
I don't know I don't remember the exact
story but he was talking about how there
are land mines everywhere and to
navigate these fields there are
footsteps and you're jumping from
footstep to footstep in the dirt because
you know it's the only place that's the
only way you know that you're safe and
you won't blow up
and I was talking about going I was like
yeah we were thinking of going because
there are these people who are doing uh
what they do is they release goats into
these fields and then the goats explode
and so I was like that's a crazy story
and I want to cover that and my friend
was like don't do it it was like the
scariest most stressful disturbing thing
in my life was traversing these fields
you don't want to do it trust me and we
end up not doing it but that's the
general idea however the tank Buster
mines require the weight of a vehicle to
detonate and so those are a lot harder
to trigger and they're huge but for the
smaller landmines they just will get a
bunch of goats and Field's all yours and
then boom boom boom the goats aren't
exploding crazy yeah rough yeah they do
another thing now where they have these
big uh they're take a big ball and
there's a bunch of bamboo uh sticks
coming out with plates on the bottom so
it looks like remember those suction cup
balls you'd throw the wall and then it
would suction cup its way down yeah yeah
they look like that and they the wind
blows them around and they just blow up
as they bounce around on land mines
because they're pretty heavy
yeah and then they just get damaged and
keep going until eventually they fall
apart I would I'm thinking that you
could maybe vibrate the soil and Trigger
them all at once if you could somehow
set up like Tesla was working on sending
electrical they're mechanical I mean
you're not I would say you're on the
right track you would need to heat them
up substantially and detonate them
somehow I would not do that maybe uh
plane flying not too high up just doing
a laser sweep or something or like stick
metal poles in the ground all over the
place and then send a low frequency
through or just yes
you can navigate a field to stick poles
in the ground yeah how big is it you
know how
how much space do you need to trigger
explosives I'm telling you more
explosives you won't you will not
convince someone to invest in any of
this technology when they can send goats
into a field I'm sorry dude they're
going to be like we got too many goats
already send them in how much oh I mean
yeah but I mean for the region it's
ghosts you know and then the goats just
blow up or like an S A Strategic Defense
from above where you can like you can't
see use lidar to map the ground and see
where they are and then hit them with
lasers I mean I suppose yeah but you're
talking about expensive and high-tech
and stuff it's easier to go you're gonna
you're gonna go to the government we can
spend two million dollars in Ohio maybe
we got two million dollars for lidar or
ten thousand for a bunch of goats
they're gonna be like just do the goats
can I eat the goats when it's done yeah
you're not gonna want to pick those
things up you can't you not I mean what
if they missed a mine you don't go into
minefields like minefields are like
there's an argue a significant argument
against mines like it they get left and
behind they end up naming kids you see
you saw it through all kinds of uh mines
that were left behind after Vietnam and
stuff like that and and it it just ruins
entire regions and you have massive
amounts of death and dismembered people
and stuff and it sucks but
what do you do when you've got tanks
coming in you coming at you you know
like there's only so much so many things
that can stop a tank you know if you can
if you can knock the Treads off a tank
but with a ma with a mine then the
Tank's vulnerable they have to get out
of the tank then you can shoot the guys
that are in the tank but
if you can't stop the tanks tanks are
gonna smoke you and your buddies so you
deal with what you got you know you have
to put Minds out to stop them you put
mines out to stop him because again war
is awful war crimes are only war crimes
if uh if if
you are those yeah yeah but you know I
guess the issue today is you don't need
tanks if you can convince so while
propaganda has been a key component of
War for the past hundred plus years
propaganda nowadays is um it's it's it's
a million times where we were 100 years
ago you take a look at say a nuclear
weapon a Merv 12 Warheads 1250 times
more powerful than the the bombs trapped
on Hiroshima Nagasaki you take a look at
the explosive power and then go back in
time to the origin of the first you know
com the first time someone ever
discovered combustion or combustible
materials
and it's it's it's we're a thousand plus
years ago Chinese yeah 280.
yeah and I forgot I forgot what they
were they were doing something
impractical with them they had little
Rockets they would use to scare people
or something because they would like fly
at you and then uh it took a thousand
years to get the point where we could
just blow up an entire city with one
bomb you take a look at propaganda and
we'd have to drop pamphlets from Planes
And in 100 years we can beam our
thoughts into your brain no matter where
you are China has a massive apparatus
for manipulating the American public in
Tick Tock for the record it was a 1044
A.D when gunpowder was invented in China
what was it for did they say uh it was
four wasn't it for firecrackers just to
no but I think there was like invented
as at by accident they were trying to
make an elixir of immortality this is
according to Chinese sources well most
most discoveries are they're called
first known instances discoveries
because it was an accident so that
that's like the Moonshine thing where
they're making moonshine and then they
blow up you know that kind of cliche I
guess it started in China they were
trying to live forever so it's it's 808
A.D was the first reference yeah that's
what it says on Wikipedia yeah in the
Warring States period they had they had
rifles they weren't very good archers
were actually Flying Cloud Thunderclap
erupter hmm
so right I think it was uh yeah they
were they were shooting stuff out of it
yeah I don't know I read something that
like the initial stuff they did was just
like shock and awe they didn't really
have like yes a good way to weaponize it
yeah you scare the horses that's a big
thing yeah
and the elephants if you have to fight
sulfur rialgar salt peter and honey
smoke and Flames results that the hands
and faces have been burnt and even the
whole house where they have been working
burned down wow yeah that's crazy and
the Chinese invented the compass 1000
years before Europeans did
crazy right nice they've been doing they
were doing all sorts of crazy stuff I
love this Chinese man they never really
they didn't really capitalize on on the
potential though like it it they did
well you know that's what's interesting
about as an Asian I can say this okay
about Asian culture is that very smart
yes but not a lot of creativity and
that's why even today you see throughout
also a lot of history right
Chinese invented gunpowder weren't using
it practically yeah who started using it
in a room because you had to think
outside the box you've never seen this
before right and there's a very Asian
culture of you know sort of this
submissive hey follow the strict line
you know do this do that but not a lot
of creativity and I think you see this
even in China for school if you want to
come to American school or whatever like
they'll just train your whole life to
take the S18 you probably get a perfect
score but then what after that what
happens when you have to be say an
engineer and you have to actually think
creatively right and it's something
lacking in a lot of Asian culture I love
that for a thousand years they have
gunpowder these uh Southeast Asians
Chinese are like look at the stuff we
made look what happens when you light it
like whoa and then Europeans like
I could kill a lot of people with that
and then they were like wait what to be
fair the idea of killing people with it
did come from China I don't want to take
that away from them right they have
their their whatever it's called the
was it uh Hua long Jing what's that it's
the the Chinese military treaty what is
this uh oh this is an a flying cloud
Thunderclap erupter and it was like a
gun it looks like they loaded it with
powder they put a hole in it man that's
crazy Cannon like a shotgun yeah it's
like a cannon shotgun and it just shoots
like metal and rocks and stuff they
would just use yeah just
ballista I think uh George Washington
used to do that because they didn't
they're running low on munition so they
just shove whatever they could find into
the Cannons and just blast them so
you're getting hit with rocks sticks
pieces of metal but boot I gotta I gotta
tell you it is really crazy when you
think about it that's like the rare all
the way around the stupid stuff that we
know from video games and movies would
make you a warlord God like demigod in
in a thought 2000 years ago or a
thousand years ago you'd show up and be
like oh yeah I know how to you know
start a fire I know how to like you know
give me some bat crap and we'll start
making some gun puddle by making what
and then you'll you'll be like what here
eat this mold and you'll feel better
they're like what are you talking about
see that red rocket right there see that
red rock over there yeah melt it what do
you mean melt it just light it on fire
let's let's roll and then it's like
all right look like I have no idea how
to make steel but I know it exists which
means I could go to them and be like you
need to like get carbon and iron and
start doing something and that is an
advancement Leaps and Bounds above how
long it took about like if just the fact
that I can tell I'm like oh you need uh
like bat crap you know just like
we know little bits here and there that
took humans thousands tens of thousands
of years to figure out and we just like
watched a movie once and we have
fragments of that information that if
you went back in time and said look man
I have no idea how to make gunpowder but
I saw something about bat crap once
you've just jumped someone up 10 years
20 years yeah thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time